giáo sư mấy lần giám đốc trung tâm nghên cứu đồng năm á đại học ngoại lưỡbất trình trở rằng
những năm gần đây, lật miệt tự năm 2020, đường đến nay,
lãnh đạo hay đàn, hay nước đã suy trí giáo liệu tiếp súc mật thiết thung qua các chuyến tham cấp cao
điện đầm và chào đổi thường xuyên về các vấn đề sông phương cũng như quốc tế
để ila đềnh tàn quan trọng giúp cùng cố lòng tin chính trị,
lòng thời tạo động lực tuyp đầy quan hệ Việt Nam Trung Quốc kết thục phát triển on đec thực chất
và có biết đợi khuy xuống,
việc ký trí chá bội thường xin dưới lãnh đạo các cao không chỉ giúp tăng cường tích cạnh trình trị
tạo được kiện sự lý hiệu qua và ký thời các phấn đề này sinh,
một dân hấp thác mà còn có phần làm gió phương cướng hấp thác,
sát định các một tiêu và nhẹ vụ trọng tâm trong phát hệ sáng khương.
Chính cơ sở đó, giáo sư cho rằng,
chúng thăm Trung Quốc của tổng bị thư chụt tích nước tổ lâm,
tương ngày 1 bốn đến ngày 1 bài tháng tư năm 2020,
có thể đạt được nhiều kết quả tích cực.
Không chỉ dừng lại ở việc tăng cường giận thức trụng giữa lãnh đạo hai nước,
chúng thăm còn được ki vào sẽ tạo bức tiến mới trong hấp tắt thức chất chình cắt linh vực.
Yêu kinh tế thương mạnh đầu tư kết nối hạ tần và rau lưu nhân văn.
Tổ tiến tưởng rằng trong thời gian tởi,
quan hệ vực nâm Trung Quốc sẽ tiếp tục là được những mức phát triển mới.
Chuyến thăm là nài,
của tổn bị thương trụ tính nước tổ lâm,
tổn bị vọng sẽ đắt nhiều kết quả quan trọng.
Trong bỏng có khả năng ký kếm một số phá thận hấp tác,
đồng thời thuốc lợi hai bây giờ là thêm nhiều nhân tức trông về các vấn đề lớn.
Tức ở mấy tỏ lạv quan và đánh giả tích cực quay trên mọng phát triển của quan hệ hai nước trong thời gian tởi.
Bây giờ, chúng nó, trong mỗi cạnh quan hệ vực nâm Trung Quốc
tất tục được cùng cố trên đình tạng lối tác hợp các chính được tòn diệt.
Và tổn đồng chia sẽ tương lai cối ghét chính lượng.
Chuyến thăm được ki vào sẽ góp phần cực thể hoa các định hưởng lớn
thành những chương trình hợp tác thiết thật.
Hếu quá hơn, mạnh lại hợp ý kết thực cho nhân dân hành hướng
đồng thời đồng có phát triển trong cuộc vực và trên thế giới.